are these the men who killed the
president
arms bound and forced to the ground
they're publicly paraded by haitian
police
they believe they're all part of an
international hit squad
today we presented these assassins to
the population
there were 26 of them we captured 17
among them 15 colombians we identified
them with their colombian passports
there are two haitian americans among
those captured
[Music]
three died during capture and another
eight are still on the run
also on display an arsenal of weapons
authorities say the group was heavily
armed and highly trained
the colombian men captured all
ex-military
their government says it will cooperate
the information indicates they are
colombian citizens retired members of
the national army
we have given instructions from the
national government to our police and
the army
to collaborate in the investigation to
clarify these facts immediately
outside the police station there is
anger the president wasn't
popular with many but his assassination
has shocked and appalled
this man says the president never
listened but nobody is happy at the way
he died
the attack happened at the presidential
residence
we don't know who's behind it but it was
organized and deadly
that was a tremendous uh coup
uh to the democracy in itself when uh
people for personal interests um
get to the point to assassinate
a president in exercise
there is a heightened tension and an
increasing police presence
haiti is no stranger to chaos and
killing
the worry now this begins another
chapter
of violent instability laura bundock sky
news